- Il n'y aura pas de parade
pour la victoire de l'arméeymym.
Ce qui défile, ce sont
des maisons brûlées, éventrées,
des édifices gouvernementauxe ee
l'occupation, dont on voit
encore les traces burinées
sur les petits commerces etququs
russes, que Lyman paiera
longtemps.
"La Russie règne", peut-onlire e
ces soldats ukrainiens q
ont libéré la ville il y a
quelques jours.ntntntntntntntnt.
Seuls quelques habitants
déambulent d'un pas lourd
qui trahit l'état de chocttttttt
et rappelle que la ville
n'est pas tout à fait fantôme.
Le choc n'efface pas
des rencontres. Ils ne veulent
pas parler. Que pourraitnn
dire de toute façon?
(vrombissement de scie à chaîne)
se préparer à l'hiver
qui s'installerarorop vite.
Avant que tout ce qui a été
détruit ne soit reconstruit,
ne soient remplacées, que
le gaz ne isisse offrir
de quoi se chauffer.
L'hôpital ne sert plus
lui prendre un peu de bois
po s se faire un feu.
veut dire amour.
"Il en fdrdrait beaucoup plus
aux hommes", dit-elle.
"Nous avions très peur.
Ce n'est pas que l'on a supporté
l'occupation dit-elle,ueueueueue
ne pouvait l'arrêter. Je ne
sais pas ce qui va arriver
maintenant. Mais pourquoivévévé"
C'est sa foi inébranlable qui
lui permet de tenir aujourd'hui.
Mais elle ne comprend pasmbmbmb.
chacun à leur manière, dit-elle.
Les enfants pleuraient
ils avaient peur. Et
rien comprendre. Ils avaient
faim, ils ont ufuffert à cause
de nous. Nous sommes pourtant
intelligents, nous devrionsesess
de nos gestes, mais
il n'y aucune pénitence",
déplore Lubov. e e e e e e e e e
stratégique importante
pour l'Ukraine et hautement
symbolique.
la défaite ici est humiliante.L,
il annexait la ville, après
des référendum
la pointe du fusil, et déclarait
Lyman, située dans la régi
de Donetsk, et trois autres
régions de l'Ukraine, russes,
Selon l'armée ukrainienne,
jusqu'à 5000 soldats russes
étaient encerclés à Lyman.
été faits prisonniers, combien
ont fui et combien sont morts.
Pour seul compte-rendu,
le minis
de l'Ukraine a déclaréque la maé
redéployée dans des sacs
mortuaires ou en captivité.
Les armes et les munitions
en battant retraite sont
maintenant entre les mains
de leurs adversaires ukrainiens
de les retourner contre eux.
Ici, des ogives, de la poudre
explosive, des lances-roquettes.
plus d'armes que l'Union
européenne", nous lance,
euphorique, le commandant qui
nous montre son butin de guerre,
mais ne veut pas être identifié.
Avec les avancées récent
se multiplient, ils paraissent
galvanisés, les soldats
ukrainiens. Au sud d
et ici, dans l'est, en avant
toute pour reprendre à la Russie
un autre villa
Vite, avant l'hiver et les
risques d'ensesement qu'il
comporte. L'exaltation se
lit sur ce
ne pouvons révéler. Mais elle
ne mquque pas la fatigue,
l'amertume, la douleur
La haine de l'ennemi aussi.
"Vous ne couperiez pas
le bras de celui qui fait mal
votre fils?", demande ce soldat.
"Que ferievovous?
Nous leur rendons la pareille.
Nous n'allons pas les caeueueue.
Ils ont fait beaucoup de mal
et ça suffit."
Personne ne se souviendra d'eux,
qu'à ceux qui n'ont pas survécu
à ldedernière bataille.
"Plusieurs de nos ho
sont morts. Il n'y avait
plus que mon commaant et moi,
raconte celui-là. Ces bâtards
nous ont tiré
Vous devez le voir
pour comprendre.
Je ne peux pas trouverlelelelel"
Ils soufflent un peu avant
de poursuivre plus à l'est.
C'est la seule route quiououous
relativement sécuritaire
à la ville de Lyman. La route
elle-même a été déminée, mais
contiennent encore énormément
d'engins explosifs, de mines
et de guet-apens.
Les mines antipersonnel etisisis
dans les boisés. Peintes en
vert, elles se confondent dans
le paysage. Une menace qui reste
malgré que seuls l t t t t t t .
Les équipes de déminage en
ont pour des jours avant de
désamorcer les plus évidente
(explosion)
Mais ifafaudra des mois
avant de pouvoir éliminer
qui reste de ceux qui ont tenté
d'emprunter cette route dans des
Lyman avec l'avancée de l'aree
ukrainienne : des uniformessssss
trousses médicales, queleses
grenades. Tout doit être vérifié
avant
Dans les villages qui mènent
à Lanan, la guerre n'avait pas
attendu février dernier pour
les villageois ont vu tantôt
les combattants séparatistes
prorusses débarquer, tantôt
Tour à tour, encore et encore.
Ce cratère témoi
passage dévastateur de l'armée
russe. Ici, celududu retour
par force des Urkainiens.
Plus rien ne
Sauf cette petite maison
dont l'enttitien détonne
parmi la dévastation.
Un vie
c'est noté sur sa porte.
Il t tout vécu, tout vu,
tout noté méticuleusement.
de raconter. Pas maintenant.Rev.
Pour le moment, il attend
de voir si lui et sa ménagerie
vont survivre au prochain
Vladimir Poutine a décidé
qu'il était Russe maintenant.
Ses soldats, il en est
convaincu,
de plus cribler les fenêtres
de sa maison de leurs balles
Ici Marie-Eve Bedar